[Music]
[Music]
nothing nothing you're the spider-man
from YouTube
what are you doing in my room mailing me
and you said we're gonna finish it this
far she doesn't know why me mr. Stewart
knows doesn't make my soup but that's it
are you an Avenger basically everyone
that she's not let me do this anymore
okay okay I'll level with you I was
thinking if there's a secret this book
reducing has ever happen to me I can't
believe this Hey what are you hiding
Peter
I'm skinny out okay finally here we go
good evening Peter oh you have 576
possible laughter you're from the
nation's ha ha ha
I can keep that suit yeah
don't fit me where's our next retreat
what next mission
we'll call you all right that's not a
hug just grab the toe for you all right
there yet
all right kid good luck out there
hey Peter you going tonight I can't
tonight I got the stark internship
what's up guys here's my report for
tonight I stopped grants that bicycle
hey could you do me a favor hold on to
that I helped us the old lady and she
bought me a churro
so how was nice I just feel like I could
be doing more wait a minute you guys
aren't the real Avengers hope gives it
away you move I'm working on
these weapons are crazy dangerous listen
Peter they're people who handle the sort
of thing can't you just be a friendly
neighborhood spider-man
activating parachute
the world's changing boys it's time we
change to my chance to prove myself we
have a Spanish quiz you gotta get better
at this part of the job
where you going what are you hiding
Peter I'm just getting younger by
there's a ton of other social systems in
here but we're all disabled by the
training wheels protocol treating me
like a kid but you are a kid stop a boss
with his bare hands
NBA Finals party I need to sign off on
the guest list
hey June fight the kit you said keep it
sophisticated why do you hate fun invite
the kid okay can I please shave this off
no you may not because your team lost
therefore you have to look like me which
one go for third option
get out Friday run a final check on the
party list question Captain Steve Rogers
too soon
sending invite no way I'm gonna watch
the NBA Finals with mr. stork so you're
gonna let me go huh nice try buddy
[Applause]
[Music]
and I just flipped in hey just a second
coming
wealth in Walsall the rich the powerful
I don't care about us it's pick up after
with eat their table scraps these alien
bastards it tough you got to use the
stuff they use the world's change this
time we change to wait next mission will
call you keep it a little more mentoring
if you're real assets than - that's not
a hug and just grabbing the tow for you
oh all right good good luck out there
someone is collecting stuff from
Avengers battles I'm building these
crazy weapons this is my chance to prove
myself
what if somebody had died to different
story right because that's on you I
wanted you to be better eight years
without any trouble from those bozos up
in stark tower and it's all bastard and
red tights shows up he thinks he can
tear down everything I've built
I've got a Plane full of brand-new
Avengers weaponry to load up we're gonna
put them out of business we're gonna
take everything they got
[Music]
do you know him - yeah still issue
[Music]
what's up guys so to become an Avenger
are there like trials or an interview do
me a favor can't you just be a friendly
neighborhood spider-man just stay close
to the ground you just a spider-man from
you two
can you summon an army of spiders oh
yeah No
do you know him - miss doshy can I try
those who them the rich and the powerful
like start they don't care about us
the world's changing boys time we change
to these weapons a crazy dangerous
mission Peter forget the flying monster
guy the people who handle this sort of
thing you later weapons Berger was a 230
you missed it
what if somebody dies I was just trying
to be like you I wanted you to get
better I'm gonna need a suit back well
nothing without this suit if you're
nothing without this suit then you
shouldn't have it I screwed up you need
to stop carrying the weight of the world
on your shoulders I want you to
understand I'll do anything to protect
my family I know you know what I'm
talking about
don't mess with
because I would kill you and everybody
in your love
the guy is still out there I've just got
to do this on my own
just don't do anything stupid
all right yeah
I keep the suit of course doesn't fit me
hey guys what's up get your PIN number
wait a minute
you got the real event just I can tell
hope gives it away
you have 78 foundation weapon
whoa that was awesome don't spare me
don't mess with everybody you want
you move them or not here we go they
know him to be me up
[Music]
sup guys wait a minute
you guys aren't the real avenge just I
can tell hope gives it away
Oh
[Music]
listen new top know you've seen that
before
know what that's skirt you should
probably stop staring with Laurie it's
creepy though too late guys are losers
so to become an Avenger other like
trials or any movie just don't do
anything I would do and definitely don't
do anything I wouldn't do
there's a little gray area in there and
that's where you operate oh all right
it's not a hug then just grab the top
for you all right good good luck out
there
listen I know school sucks you still
with us uh yeah yeah
I know you want to save the world but
you're not ready yet you're the sweater
man
no I'm not I'm not this is just a
costume this is for the ceiling stay
close to the boy I'll stay out of
trouble
[Music]
forget the flying monster guy there are
people who handle this sort of thing
treating me like a kid all the time but
you are a kid this is my chance to prove
myself
what is going on with you I'm sorry I'm
so busy I'm slammed cuz I will kill you
and everybody blow
underoos everyone
[Applause]
I get to keep the suit of course doesn't
fit me just don't do anything I would do
and definitely don't do anything I
wouldn't do
there's a little gray area in there and
that's where you operate guys wait a
minute you want the real Avengers
[Music]
but this does not mean you're an Avenger
okay so were wondering oh it's not a hug
I'm just grab the door for you oh all
right good good luck out there
the world's changing boys time we change
to missing Peter
forget the flying monster guy
there are people who handle this sort of
thing like a kid but you are a kid this
is my chance to prove myself
don't mess with me because I will kill
you and everybody in your club
[Music]
[Music]